facebook says decision on whether trumpy
uh ban will be overturned coming
wednesday cnn business story
their oversight board will announce its
long-anticipated decision on the fate of
former president trump facebook account
at 9 a.m eastern standard time on
wednesday announced monday morning
the board said last month that it had
received 9 000 plus public responses
concerning trump's indefinite
suspension from facebook and instagram
facebook suspended trump's account
following the january 6 capital rights
and later referred the decision to the
court-like oversight board
an independent body which has the power
to reverse facebook content decisions
and set president
uh for the company later that month
facebook asked the oversight board for
ruling on whether to let
trump's suspension stand saying the
significance of the matter warranted its
independent review
thoughts well i is there anybody that
thinks it's going to get overturned i
i don't think there's a chance in hell
that he's back on
i think there is okay oh and i i just
don't think there is this is the
facebook supreme court um it's happened
six times where they've done it what i
think they overruled it
twice couldn't decide one time but
no i don't think so and and here's what
they're going to lean on they're going
to lean on the one thing that got him
banned it was it was
the video where he says we love you we
think you're very special i mean
look you might not agree with the rules
but the rules are in place
and there's consequences to having a
message like that on that day
and my prediction is i don't think he's
going to be back on facebook
okay what do you think i'm kind of 50 50
with it but i also may look at
look at look at it like they're looking
at him as competition you know because
there is rumors going around that he's
going to launch a social media platform
or partner with someone as well too so
if this is going to be your social media
you don't want to give him
your platform that opportunity to
promote and bring followers over from
that particular platform as well so i'm
kind of 5th in regards to if they will
or won't do it
i know that they're getting a lot of
pushback on it as well but you know
council culture they don't care don't
you think it's a little bit more
difficult to just say you're going to
start your own social media platform
yeah yeah absolutely yeah absolutely
once more when you're
when you're at his level it's not about
him doing it these things are already in
the works you partner with individuals
who have already
done the work and then you put the money
behind it in your influence and
tied out that you have it so do you
think they will or they won't would you
he said he's 50 50. yeah i'm 50 50 only
if they will if they won't
um i think more than the trump situation
here
is this the power of big tech like the
fact that
the facebook gods the overlords are like
well
should we or should we and not allow the
former president of the united states to
be on our platform
i think it's such a huge decision that
it's
it's ridiculous and i'm in case you
haven't gotten the memo not a trump fan
in the least right but i think that you
should at least
allow the former president united states
to have
a place on your platform now if you want
to put
like literally behind every message that
he does
this message has been fact checked and
he's definitely a liar and
you know he over exaggerates and he's
definitely divisive you want to do all
that
but to ban him from being on a platform
is ridiculous and don't forget i think
trump's
approval ratings were hovering in the
low 40s facebook and mark zucker
mark zuckerberg's are hovering in the
twenties and thirties yeah but those
they're right
to be worse than trump is you know it's
pretty bad i just think
their their history they're not do how
much heat would they take from all the
other social media companies
if they allowed him back it would put
this this pressure then on twitter to
allow him back i
i strongly believe there's no chance one
thing i know for sure
we'll be covering this story on thursday
right yeah i think that i think there's
a chance i think there's a chance
because i think this is if you remember
uh
zuck took a couple positions where he
said look we're a
uh we're a content we're a social media
website so we don't dictate what
policies we put in what policies we
don't and he made some decision that
pissed off the left
i don't know if you remember this was
like two years ago year and a half ago
they were not happy about the position
he took and he gets backlash from both
sides all the time you got to give
credit to zuck on the one end where
both sides hate him there's almost a
little bit of credibility when both
sides hate you
at times rather than just one side
ratings are yeah so
20 but but the point is the reason why
both sides hate him is because sometimes
he
takes a stand that is not republican and
sometimes he takes a stand that's not
democratic so
i think there is a chance they may allow
him back with certain restrictions where
your
every post has to be approved type of
situation where they may come out and
say the post has to be
we created a committee that all they do
is watch trump's post
and they say here's what is posted do we
want to report this put it up
and maybe something like that but i do
think there's a 10 20 chance i was going
to ask you you're
[Applause]
six times it's been overturned upheld
them twice
one time could uh they couldn't come up
with the decision
so they have actually overturned it six
times the majority huh
look trump's news is getting out he's
sending email to the media nowadays he
responds and puts
email says oscar needs to go back to
this you know this needs to go back to
this
so his message is being picked up he's
just sending emails as much as
horse is not at that of course it's not
let me
but if i have to choose if i have to
choose you got twitter you got youtube
you got facebook meaning google right so
youtube
so you've got facebook google twitter
who's most likely to let them back on
not twitter okay so that's last that's
the last yeah we ain't coming back so
who's most likely
facebook youtube yeah i think it's
probably gonna be facebook youtube then
twitter
here's another thing to consider do you
think there's a possibility he's
enjoying his life
with a little less stress no you don't
think so i think he's such a sore loser
that there's
he's zero percent happy about what's
going on right now i believe he's
festering
and he he's ready to come back and just
do it just to annoy a lot of people
at the end of the day he's also 72 maybe
he's tired 70
he's not sure trump don't get tired he's
74 74 he's got the body like an 84 year
old in the mind of a four-year-old he's
gonna be back baby
i don't know man it's a comfortable
lifestyle up there why do you what is it
about
trump that you enjoy well you so
that's a great question um i i've never
known not to like trump you know i come
from
an environment from an urban environment
where we've always admired trump you
know from just from
from a celebrity standpoint from the
gold buildings from the rap videos from
the
from the movie appearances it wasn't it
was never political it was popular it
was the only type of political that took
a
very people told me you turned since
they told me not to like them just
because and then there are certain
things that i understand about human
beings i understand that i don't have to
agree with everything 100 percent
i like i like strength i like
individuals that say what they
say and they're unorthodox and they're
untraditional which is why i talk about
the electrician that's
you know that's unapologetically
different right and i think he
represented that for the time and moment
in regards to what our country needed
and it was simplistically just based
upon that so were there things that
you're like look
i appreciate them i respect them but uh
yeah that i can't do what were those
some tweets
and some sometimes just having that uh
uh that certain stance on
on answering questions straightforward
in regards to white supremacy
and things of that nature like you could
just go ahead and do it
even though you've answered it and that
was the biggest thing he had to say you
got to answer the same questions over
and over i know that it can be
get redundant i get it all the time man
i just answered that like literally two
seconds ago just
what about like the confederate flags he
was kind of yeah you know not
siding with taking it down obviously you
probably have
strong opinions on that right well
honestly i wasn't really
educated in regards to what that truly
meant at that particular time in regards
to why people felt
forward or even felt against it but i
also just
the foundation of choice like if that's
what you're for that's what you're for i
don't have to agree with it and so i
never took a hard stance when it came to
that because
it doesn't it doesn't bother me it like
my life continues to be with my life
does that not bother you adam likes to
be emotional
it's part of his uh well no one is no
one is bringing it up to me like it's
not in
uh there's not anyone in my yard you
know making me acknowledge it or
anything of that nature so i just don't
own
every every issue in every every um
activism type of thing people want me to
be a part i told you a pat i'm working
on my emotions
i'm getting much better i'm trying to
hold it in
so okay we'll see wednesday tomorrow we
get the news yes
uh folks if you're watching what do you
think likelihood let's let's let's do a
survey here i'd love to hear the
likelihood if you say there's no way in
the world they're going to approve him
smash the thumbs up button
if you say they're going to approve him
he's going to be
back on facebook put the thumbs down so
if you enjoyed this little short segment
from the podcast that we did here's
another short segment to watch
or if you want to see the entire podcast
click over here take care everybody
bye-bye